all right uh welcome everyone uh to ddps
seminar today uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all uh please
mute yourself during the talk um but if
you have questions you can unmute and
ask question during the talk but um
otherwise if you want to be um don't you
don't if you don't want to interrupt the
um the presentations you can use chat
room and post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end second today's ddps seminar is open
to external audience therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel uh that's about it let
me introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host Dr Kong M who is a
research scientist at IBM TJ Watson
Research Center he received the PHD in
applied math from Brown University in
2011 before joining IBM and research in
2013 he was a post doctoral fellow at
the Lawrence berley National Lab Dr y
has been working on a range of research
areas from soft metaphysics to
atmospheric sciences since joining IBM
research his research interest has been
focused on hybrid physics statistics
models and deep learning for random
dynamical systems today uh Dr y will
talk about reducing data resolution for
better reconstruction super resolution
of Navia Stokes flow I'm sure we are
going to hear a wonderful talk now let
me um before we before I pass the button
to um the doct Y let me ask a in some
informal uh questions to get to know him
better
um so
um I know you like to travel with family
and I happens to know that your wife is
you know some artist yeah job um uh if
you can share your the most favorite uh
the place you have been um so far and
and Hell us yeah so it's it's more like
a so my spare time is mostly devoted to
helping out my wife and she's actually
painter but she also does a photography
and so on so we kind of most impress uh
most interesting place is we traveled to
Iceland so we went to Iceland like a uh
three times or in the winter so that you
don't really got interrupted by any
other people so it it was quite
fascinating uh if you go Iceland in
Winter always be prepared because you
know sometime things can happen uh one
time uh the first time we went to ice
land then we actually uh got stuck in a
mountain and stayed night in the car and
the next day we walked down the mountain
to get rescued so it's it was very
fascinating place to us so was it
because of the snow storm yeah yeah
because of snow I we rented a small car
which couldn't move so I tried to shovel
it out but it didn't work so yeah next
day we walked like 3 4 hours to find a
farm and get rescued so oh my goodness
that sounds devast devastating um no it
was interesting it was interesting okay
well thank you for
sharing okay well thank you for sharing
uh interesting story okay the floor is
yours okay great uh thank you Dr CH for
the introduction uh and the invitation
so I'm G from IBM research the topic I'm
going to talk today is mostly about like
a good oldfashioned state estim problem
but here the interest is that uh when we
use super
resolutions sometimes we can get a
better reconstruction of the uh ground
choer state particularly when the data
is noisy so this is the joint study with
my collaborators uh Maggie uh Mike and
sagy so in this study we almost all
contribute to the equal Maggie mostly
did the numerical simulations and Mike
and sey were sponsor for the theoretical
derivations I just did a little bit of
everything so so uh this is actually
motivation of the study when you have
some observation of physical phenomena
it's very difficult to get away from uh
corruption uh this is one example how
they actually measure the fluid velocity
the device shown on top left is called
particle tracking vetry we call it PTV
so in this ptb uh they have suspensions
of neutrally bant particles and the
movement of this neutral bant particle
is captured by High speeed camera so
that you eventually end up with some uh
images something like a uh bottom left
and then if you can identify the
positions of the particle comparing uh
both images then you can find you can
approximate the velocity at some
locations
and you can imagine uh if we use this
kind of device then the measurement we
are getting out of this PTV is highly
noisy so the higher resolution
measurement we can get is something look
like top left corner on the right figure
that uh although we can have some small
case structures the the data is highly
corruptive so it's very difficult to
understand what really going on and then
later if we change the uh say some
parameters such as the length of average
or grid space or length of correlations
then you can move from the top left to
the bottom right so at this stage now we
have the much smooth velocity field but
the problem is that now all the high
small scale structures went away so now
the question we have is that how can we
uh what kind of resolution we want to
work with and uh how can you deal with
the
so one of the uh interesting thing one
of the interesting one of the interest
is that if we can start from this bottom
right corner that's very smoothed out
low resolution uh information and if you
can use this information to reconstruct
this High uh scale a very high wave
number phenomenal then that's going to
be the ideal scenario and that's where
the super resolution comes in so super
resolution is the is not like a new area
super resolution has been studied for a
few decades now the uh classical super
resolution problem is actually using a
sequence of low resolution im images to
reconstruct the high resolution data so
when you have some observation function
which is fixed uh the observation
function in this case is denoted by this
uh Matrix M for
example then this high resolution the gr
data is projected on this low resolution
image by the observation function and
then uh as we combine different frames
of moving object then different
different areas are captured by this
this observation function then the basic
idea is that we can stitch these
different information together to
generate the high resolution uh high
resolution image so uh in this example
they actually shows that if we combine
these many uh like 55 low resolution uh
frames then they could come up with this
high resolution uh high resolution um uh
reconstruction of ground
TRS but we uh with the development of De
learning now uh the idea of super
resolution has been changes that instead
of solving optimization problems to
reconstruct higher resolution
information by using a low resol
sequence of low resolutions now the idea
is that we do every of these
reconstruction in the training time so
once we have a tremendous amount of
training data then we don't we can
actually uh find a structure uh from
this low resolution image to generate
high resolution reconstruction so that
instead of having uh multiple images now
in deep learning time we are mostly
looking at a single image super
resolution that we just give this
information and we want to zoom in to we
want to zoom in to this uh rectangles
and get a high resolution image so this
result show this super resolutions for
this super resolution for this
particular area and this by cubic is
just like a simple B interpolation which
is mostly similar to the low resolution
data we have but when you apply this uh
de learning method as is shown here uh
the deing method uh provides much more
realistic images than the than the uh
simple byic
interpolations so uh thanks to the
success of deep learning in this single
image super resolutions now it has been
applied to many different physical
problems in first example shown here uh
now they are they went to real extreme
the super resolution problems that
people usually looked at is mostly like
four times or eight times super
resolution but in this particular study
they looked at a 50 times super
resolution problem that uh they they
first start from very very low
resolution image and then they obsc it
to the medi uh they have two uh models
one is that of scaling from low
resolution to medium resolution and they
have another models that's of scaling
from medium resolution to high
resolutions so that they claimed that if
if we have this stepwise approaches they
could achieve 50 times super resolutions
and the model was applied to some global
scale climate problems uh in this case
they uh uh the what shown on the left is
the original low resolution image and
using the method they can uh generate
they can generate the uh super
resolution data shown on the right which
looks much more
realistic uh but uh more quantitative
study is shown on the right in this case
in this study they are looking at the to
channel flows so here uh it's mostly
like a four time super problem the
rightmost column shows the d d num
simulation that's the gr CH and when
they Supply the low resolution data
which is shown on the left then uh their
uh neuron Network can generate the
higher legation data which looks much
realistic and what's very what's
interesting in this study is that when
you look at the energy spectrum of the
super resolution research that is shown
on
here in this uh energy Spectrum the
black line is the ground truth and the
vertical line shown here is the C of
length meaning that uh they generate the
low resolution data by using spectral
filter which cuts off all the all the
high wave number
information after the Reconstruction the
the energy spectrum of the reconstructed
field is shown as symbols which is
almost identical to the ground truth so
it means that uh this super resolution
method can actually recover the uh
ground Truth uh you know you know uh
which is very generating the images that
is very close to the physical phenomena
that's happening but what we actually
need to uh remember here is that even
though there was success in super in
applying super resolutions for the
physical problems the super resolution
is in POS problem so that it you don't
really have a unique solutions to match
the low resolution data so there can be
infinite number of solutions to match
the low resolution data from high
resolutions one example shown here is
that uh on the left we can have
apparently blood image of Obama but
after the Reconstruction they get
someone else and what is shown here is
that they have the very bload image of
some person and they uh their neuron
network is generating many different
possibilities and all of these
possibilities apparently different
people uh can uh match the low
resolution data so in a sense super
resolution is POS problem there is no
unique solution so one possibility is
that if we have the rec super resolution
reconstruction of single image to image
then the reconstructed field May satisfy
the kinematic conditions for example if
we have incompressible flows then it may
satisfy the mass conservation but there
is no guarantee that this satisfied SN
satisfi the reconstruct field satisfies
this a dynamic constraint such as moment
conservation
so there are uh new studies that comes
out they in this in these studies people
are started looking at the sequence to
sequence reconstruction so now we are
going back to the classical uh time of
the we try to reconstru we try to do the
super resolution based on the sequential
information and in to actually satisfies
the dynamic constraint so in this but uh
uh the uh top in in this study what they
did is that they are looking at the
sequence of low resolution images
centered around the high resolution
reconstruction they want to have and
then uh in in this plot the figure on
the right is ground truth and the one
left is the multiple multiple time step
snapshot reconstruction and the left is
single SN reconstruction so it looks
almost the same but uh the multiple
snapshot is a little bit better so when
you look at the statistical properties
uh that is shown here again this is
energy spectrum of talant flows the
black line is ground chose and here this
blue line is the multiple snapshot
reconstruction and this uh red line is a
single snapshot reconstruction so they
actually showed that having multiple
snapshots to the reconstruction super
resolution has a better accuracy than
single snapshot what single snapshot to
snapshot of super
resolutions and this is the study that
just came out uh in this study they also
have the similar idea that um instead of
minimizing the error uh between low
resolution and high resolution in know
in each snapshot now they are proposing
to have a Time marching error to satify
the Dynamic
constraint and in figure on the right uh
in this figure the left First Column is
ground ches second column is the low
resolution data they essentially uh take
the scares and and the compute the and
get the average inside of scare and the
right columns are super resolution
reconstructions using this Dynamic loss
and you can see that they are very
closed with okay do you have question
yes uh doctor can you talk about
conservation properties like Mass
momentum and energy in this super
resolution uh because they are important
for incompressible flows yeah that's
actually very good question so um in
this case uh that's actually one of the
purpose why we want to why this author
was going into this uh this kind of Time
marching loss to the Time marching Ross
essentially uh having been compelling
the moment momentum conservations
between the ground juice data and the
super and the super resolution models to
satisfy uh so that it's likely to
satisfy the moment conservation but in
always that uh the this is this provide
a soft constraint not hard constraint so
always the issues with this de leing
model is that it's very hard to make the
model to satisfy the hard constraint so
we it may approximately satis the moment
conservation but not exactly also same
story go to the mass conservation so
usually you need to have the actual mass
conservation in uh in the uh in in Ro
function otherwise it's going to be very
tricky to uh trick it to uh satisy okay
so what the different another question
here yeah it says uh the Sean is asking
what is the definition for the N Theta
and variable uh
fee oh this fee is Time marching
operator and U is ground truth
velocity and then uh here what it is
that this is first C is a projection to
the low resolution data and then n we
and then we apply n for the
Reconstruction then applying it to the
time matching operator so we first to
have the ground choose to the low
resolutions
and then neural network to reconstruct
High resolutions and then applying Time
marching operator and comparing the two
so the the anyway the message here is
that if you look at this error plot so
this figure the vertical line is the L2
error horizontal line is some
computation parameters and this green
line is a single snapshot super
resolutions and the uh this red line
this blue line is much
mapia super resolutions and it shows
that multia super resolutions has a
smaller errors than uh the single so it
has better uh it has a better
approximation of ground shoes and what
but what's interesting in this study is
that uh uh they compare the flow field
predictions using the data ass
simulations and the super resolutions
data assimilation in this case may use
neonian ning and then what they found is
that when there is a noise in the
initial
conditions then in super resolutions the
noise uh in super super resolution
method uh the noise effect of the noise
doesn't propagate a lot you know in
Downstream so that the the noise is
quickly removed while they are when they
use data assimilations the noise
propagates much longer meaning the super
resolution also has some dining
capability so the uh so this Al these
study essentially say that in super
resolutions uh we we want to have some
uh Dynamic we want to improve some
Dynamic effect and that's actually what
we are interested in in uh in this study
so if we simp if we simplify the system
now we can have uh we can simplify the
system in this way that we have the
original system that that has the uh equ
that has the Time marching system of
high resolution information denoted by
mu and we and we when we and then from
this original system now we get the high
resolution information uh that is
filtered to generate the low resolution
data and then we have another system
that is called Observer this Observer
system is supposed to have the high same
equation with the high resolution system
but this Observer uh uh this Observer
system doesn't really have the same
initial conditions as well as it it
doesn't really have the direct
information of this high resolution
ground truths we only have an
observation of this low resolution
information then the and this is this
uh very simple schematic explains that
uh it captures the essence of this
Dynamic super resolution problem we are
uh looking at then the next question we
can naturally have is that uh when we
have very complex n dynamical system
that is that can be chaotic such as
nacations then for chaotic systems what
we know is that even small perturbations
eventually make the make two system
diverge but in this Observer system we
don't we don't see the ground truth of
this high resolution information we only
see the filtered are low resolution
information then the question is that
when the system is CH whether this is
super resolution model can really uh
approximate the ground truth or
not and
the uh interest and the answer to this
question is comes from very interesting
phenomena called chaos
synchronization so chaos synchronization
means that when you have two uh CH
chical systems sometimes by exchanging
informations these two chical systems
can synchronize with each other so this
is one of the early examples of chaos
synchronization that uh on the left hand
we have the uh original L law equations
L law system
and on right hand we have another L
system that is starting from different
initial conditions but what they found
is that if we share uh if we have one of
the dimensions of this original system
to derive this Observer this Observer
system then eventually we can we can get
this Observer system synchronized with
the original system so that uh this kind
of synchron synchronization of a
character system has been studied uh
studied extensively and there is a very
nicely view of this couple dynamic
system uh in this in this paper so this
kind of chaos synchron synchronization
was actually observed in tolent
flows so in this study uh they what they
in this this is a very interesting study
where they have this
navigation and they use some kind of
spectral filter
to generate the low resolution data
denoted by U1 and then now they have the
Observer system this Observer system
only using this low resolution data and
uh moving in time and what they found is
that uh this delta T is the
deviation of this uh this Observer
system from the ground shoes and then
what I found is that uh this this
deviation is actually diminishing to the
motion accuracy and the rate of this uh
decay of the of deviation is
exponentially fast so that they actually
found when uh when the
uh when when the low resolution data
covers up to 10 or 15 times cor of time
scale uh then you can the this low this
super resolution system can actually
recover the ground truth almost exactly
so here the left one is the input data
that's the low resolution data and the
right column is the uh is is the super
resolution reconstruction that that
really preserve a very small scale
characteristics and it actually
converges the original high resolution
system so the same study uh has been uh
there also has been same uh uh same
study on the chaos synchronization in NE
flows and what they suggested is that
this chaos synchronization in NE
toxication actually occurs over a wide
range of a parameters and then they they
uh suggested that this chaos
synchronization is actually a properties
of NE toxication not the spe not related
to specific data assimilation algorithms
so uh this type of
convergence of Observer system to super
resolution of J system to to to ground
truth has been studied a lot in data
simulation community so this is one of
the old study that was done by or this
is very classic study that
mathematically show prove that in 2D
turbulance that uh this
uh this super resolution uh so so data
assimilation actually converges to the
ground shoes and in more recent studies
they actually uh mathematically proofed
also in 2D flows that when you use super
when you have super resolution models
under certain conditions that this super
resolution the error of this super
resolution model uh decreases
exponentially fast and converg to the
ground truth system uh with motion
accuracy
so what essentially says is that uh when
we have a very clean system that is
knowing that doesn't contain any noise
then super resolution model have the
potential to actually reconstruct the
ground truth in in in particular for the
ne
fluid then let's go back to the uh
motivation in the beginning that uh we
start now we are we are looking at the
system that is not Noise free we are
interested in reconstruction of noise
observations then we have many different
behaviors we have uh depending on the
filter we are using we can have many
different resolutions now we want to
have some guideline that what's the
resolution we want to work with and if
we want to if we use some of these
resolutions uh whether we have a
guarantee of some kind of convergence to
the ground TR system so that so far
there are many studies of super
resolutions in for dynamic turant flows
and many physical systems but most of
most of the studies have been F have
been empirical and what we wanted to do
achieve in this study is to provide some
theoretical guideline whether this super
resolution model is actually working uh
or if it works under what kind of
conditions so so uh let me now talk
about the problem setup of our study
here we we are still looking at two di
two dimensional turbulent flows the
original system we are we are interested
is that we are using is something called
chrom flow this is essentially two
dimensional incompressible NE toxication
and here the driving force is given by
some sin some Sina function some sign
function and then uh the computational
domain is periodic so we have 2 pi in 2
pi in both directions and we use sud
spectral Sol with 512 uh mode in each
directions so in the initial conditions
we randomly generate the initial
conditions by by seing a very uh high
wave number vertices and then as time
goes uh we the vertices evolve to
generate the turent field as shown here
the this plot is starting this plot is a
Time evolution of the volt City Field
starting from time equal to 0 to
so now uh we have the Observer system
The Observer system is same as the same
as the ground through system so it is it
has it is still NE toxication Tod uh but
this Observer system has a different
initial condition than the ground system
because we don't we don't know the
initial conditions and this Observer
system is coupled to the ground Truth uh
by this feedback uh mechanism here L is
some parameter that related to the
relaxation time scale of this Observer
system to the gr ches and this C is a
low this is a low resolution projection
operator and this C is defined as in
this equation essentially what this
prior does is that we compute uh average
velocity in sub doain denoted by Omega J
and then we distribute this average over
the over this subdomain so if you look
at the figure on right then this is the
total computational domain then we we
divide this total computational domain
into a disjoint subdomains and in each
subdomain we compute the average
velocity
uh and then they distribute this aage
average velocity uh within this
subdomain so we have a piecewise
continuous uh velocity field uh in in in
the in the whole
domain and this Observer system is
solved by a second order finite
different finite element method so so
that it has lower order accuracy than
the one used for the data generation
process and uh and this opery should
satisfy some of the regularity
conditions that is shown here uh but I
will get back to this conditions later
in in the
talk and we generate the noise
observation the noise observation is
generated by adding a uh adding white
noise to the ground Cho so this is a
small y so this U is high resolution
ground chice and then we add a random
noise white noise to this ground truth
to have noise
observations and then we apply this low
resolution operator C to the high
resolution noise observation to generate
the data that we are supplying to The
Observer so this why Den not the data
and uh this figure shows the process
that the left figure uh is the ground
truth velocity and then when we add the
noise the corrupted data look looks like
the figure on the mirror and then the
low resolution projection of this
corrupted data that is we are supplying
to the super resolution model is shown
on the right
so uh so this low resolution data is of
course much less noisy than the than
this high resolution data but it is also
very different from the ground truth
because we are filtering out uh many of
the important many of the uh small scale
information
so in this uh in this uh in this uh
corruption process we don't actually
request this uh noise noise ATA to be
caution but we assume that this no this
noise has a finite variance so that we
apply we introduce a regularity
conditions this regularity condition
means that uh uh this integral inside
the bracket is essentially a variance of
the noise and this variance of the noise
M multiplied by some constant is less
than one meaning that so we we assume
that there are some positive coefficient
R which can be used to bound the
variance so as long as the noise is
bounded then this condition is is
satisfied now the main resch uh uh main
resch of the of our study is is
summarized here but here I'm not going
to uh explain details about these
theorems but essentially what we try to
show in this theorem is that uh when we
have this Observer system which is
coupled to the ground Truth by using the
low resolution uh
observation then this Observer system
converges exponentially fast to the
neighborhood of the ground shes and when
there is when there is not noise in the
observation what is found before was
that this G will exactly converge to you
but when there is a noise then then this
Observer system converges to you but it
only stage in the neighborhood not
exactly converging to the ground Sho so
that we have the Convergence Zone where
this perturbation part the velocity
field converges to to the original
ground Truth uh and once once this uh
Observer is inside of this Arrow bound
then each going it's going to stay there
without without escaping so that uh this
converion stone is globally attracting
um so this is so here uh this is the
main result of the uh study and uh let
me just briefly sketch what this theorem
actually uh derived and uh what what it
actually what it actually means so we
first start from the weak form of the
nebio ociation that here the first line
is the weak form of the uh ground Truth
uh system and the bottom is the Observer
system and we subtracted these two to
get the evolution equation of the error
uh so here in this equation what denoted
by E is the
is the error error term that the ground
choose velocity field are subtracted by
The Observer velocity field and then the
idea of this proof is that if we can
find the bound of each of the TS then we
can uh have we can understand how this
Evolution equation will behave so but
I'm not going to explain details about
all of the other TS does but what we are
interested in here is what
happens uh with something happening in
this term uh in this term f is the
driving force of the naval toxication
that's known and this capital F is uh is
the feedback Force so that this capital
F is essentially uh combination of the
driving force with this uh Observer
low resolution
input and then if we manipulate this
Capital app driving force ter now we can
decompose it into two terms one is that
we have the projection of the error and
another term is the low resolution
projection of the uh
noise and uh so that if we look at this
term now we can actually compute the
upper bound
of this inner product as is shown here
and what we are again in this upper
bound what we are interested in is only
what's happening uh with this inner
product between between the noise and
the aom so here this is actually typo it
should be a
not but anyway what we interested in is
only this uh in inner product between
noise and the Aon and then uh the bound
of this uh noise this noise in know
product is shown here so that we first
uh just write out write down the
definition of the inner product and then
we use the regularity condition that we
introduced it uh before to com to get
the bound to to get the bound of the of
this inner product and at the end at the
end of the day after doing some
manipulations now we can find the upper
bound of this uh inner product uh in
terms of the L2 error and the questioni
F Sigma is defined uh in here the sigma
depends on the size of the subdomain
this H is the side of subdomain and R is
the parameter that depends on the
variance of the
noise so uh after doing again after
doing after doing some manipulation this
is is again uh writing down this uh in a
product and we we looked at what H
what's happening inside of this you know
product between noise and error then we
uh end up with some we end up with some
conditions that we can find some uh
ction to Delta which is between Z and
one and once we have the conditions that
this Del multiplied by L2 error is
larger than the the sigma Sigma
coefficient from the regularity
conditions then what we can we can uh we
can further reduce uh the the uh
temporal uh time Evolution equation of
error into this form and then uh if we
have further conditions that the that
the first term is less than the second
term then we can even simplify the error
Evolution equation shown here so what it
essentially says is that the upper bound
of the time evolution of L2 error L2
error means that the super resolution
reconstruction and the ground choose is
bounded is exponentially uh decaying
function so we have the relaxation
process that the upper bound of L2 eror
is decaying and then to to get this term
we actually made some of the assumptions
that uh this L2 error is bigger than
this cient Sigma so in other words when
this L2 error is bigger bigger than uh
this bigger than right hand side then
error is decaying exponentially fast and
when L2 error is less than the right
hand side then we don't know we we don't
know whether it's going to decrease or
increase but uh but that is that's is
not our interest at this time so based
on this conditions now we can uh have
the zone of convergence meaning that uh
when L2 eror is Big out bigger than this
zone of convergence denoted by denoted
by here then it's already exponentially
uh exponentially fastly decreasing so
that this is J converion essentially
provides us the upper bound of L2 error
now let's look at this upper bound a
little bit more closely so that this is
the definition of the zone of error uh
the Convergence Zone then from the
regular from the regularity conditions
we had before uh again what the what's
happening inside of this bracket is is
just the uh variance average it over the
domain and let's say we we have the comp
computational Grid or data grid that is
shown here that is high resolution data
with grid size Delta X and we have
subdomain that is shown in this red
rectangles that have size H then we can
define a compression ratio uh that's the
ratio between the size of the subdomain
and the grid space then using this
compression ratio now we can uh show
that uh whatever that the average
expectation of this uh integration
inside the bracket can be written as
Sigma Square that's the variance of the
noise divided by C sare that's the
that's this compression ratio larer c
means that we have a uh qu
resolutions so using these conditions at
the using these conditions at the end of
the day we can bound all of the
expressions and we find that the zone of
convergence can be expressed by uh this
equation so that here this Omega is the
size of the computational domain and
Delta is some parameter had parameter we
can choose then uh what this equation
essentially says is that the upper bound
of error is proportional to the variance
standard deviation of the noise but
what's interesting is that it it's
actually inversely proportional to the
grid side so as long so if we it's very
counterintuitive because when you have
the high resolution information the
usual intuition is that we want to
somehow work with this high resolution
information to get a better
reconstruction but what this uh research
actually says is that if we reduce the
resolution of the uh of this super
resolution system
then we can resolution of the input data
to super resolution we can actually have
a bettery construction so that uh this
this city actually summarizes all of the
derivations all of the proof I just
outlined that uh this figure the
quantity on the left defines of The Jone
of converence and this Jone of
conversions that is the upper bound of
error is essentially decreased when you
when the data resolution gets closer so
that so here that's the theoretical now
we are trying to uh show the not we are
trying to see that if the theoretical
lur can be uh observed in the actual
numerical experiment so here we do so so
this is our line of the numerical
experiment uh the original system uh the
ne two dimensional Neo equation was was
solved by the sud sudo spectral method
and we are using 512 fre mode for to
solve this nication and the Observer
system is now solved by second the
finite element method and then again
shown on the right is uh the high
resolution grid and we have this
subdomain denoted by this uh red curve
uh and then we this uh the size of this
domain is denoted by H and we have
compression ratio that's giving us this
that's giving us the ratio of super
resolution and the noise magnitude here
is that the uh variance of noise is
proportional to the turent kinetic
energy turent kinetic energy is defined
defined on here and then we used
different we looked at the uh different
parameter range that viscosity change
from 0015 to 9 and then different noise
levels and different compession
ratios okay and the the actual uh code
is is you can find the actual code in
this uh in this GitHub report so this is
open source code you can you can
download and test
it so this is the uh uh the resarch of
the B reconstruction for the parameter
range shown here so so then now we are
looking at the compression ratio of 32
meaning that we are looking at 32 times
super resolutions so this is the ground
Chu state in the initial condition of
ground CH State and we superpose noise
to the initial State and then uh this is
a low resolution input data that is
averaged by 32 32 by 30 gr and then the
right figure shown here is is super
resolution reconstruction but initial
condition is of super reconstruction is
just like almost zero in this case and
then after some time here we are looking
at tal to 8 then uh we then uh figure on
the left ground chose and we have the
corrupted data and then eventually the
Reconstruction shown on the right is
very close to the ground truth and the
figure on the figure on the middle is
the act actual low resolution data that
was supplied to the super resolution
models so that if you look at the figure
on the bottom then the left this this is
the velocity fi in the center of the
domain uh this is the uh horizontal
velocity at the center of domain and you
can see that this is a ground choose and
this is the low resolution data and
super resolution reconstruction in this
case becomes a very close to ground
truth even though low resolution data
doesn't really have this high small
scale
structures so uh this figure is shows
the Reconstruction error at one time
snap this snapshot it's the same
snapshot at tal to 8 and here we are
looking at the error field at different
compression ratio compression ratio one
means that it's like a data assimilation
algorithm and then we apply the super
resolutions then as you can see here
that as increase the uh compression
ratio then the error gets smaller and
smaller and in this case if you look at
the color bar the color bar changes
from1 to minus one while the color bar
color bar of the gr changes from two to
minus two so that the error range here
is much smaller than the actual velocity
field and this is consistent with uh uh
the study that I explained in the
beginning that when you had uh where
they found
that the super resolution models have uh
much very strong characteristics in the
ding very strong very strong denoting
capability and we also showed that when
you use a super resolution the error
becomes much less than as you increase
the size of the uh as we increase the
size of the
subdomains and now we are looking at the
convergence of this super resolution the
relative error in this case it defined
by L2 error divided by the velocity
fluctuations and the reason is that
based on the Jone of definition of the
zone of convergence and the definition
of this uh uh variance of the noise now
what we can see is that uh this relative
error should should scale as the as the
converion stone like it should Decay at
the comple ratio so if you look at this
case so both of the
from same noise level 1.6 at different
viscosity uh what you can see is that as
we so this line is the c equal to one
meaning that there is no compression and
as we increase the uh compression ratio
the super resolution ratio then we see
that the relative error actually
decreases and then in the beginning we
also starting from different we we are
starting from uh zero Val filed so we
have different initial velocity than the
ground Cho and this the the the
deviation from the ground truth decays
exponentially fast so that is consistent
with the the theoretical predictions but
another thing we observe is that as we
increase the the size of subdomain the
super resolution ratio then it first
decrease but then eventually when we
when we decrease uh the super res when
you increase super resolution ratio
further then the error starting to
diverge the system starting to diverge
from the ground Ro so the each Force
decreasing and each going up to here uh
this because in theoretical predictions
we have some necessary conditions for
the convergence that the uh size of the
uh subdomain the ratio of the super
resolution should be bounded by some
constant multiplied by the viscosity
which is inversely proportional to the
REO
number now for the interest of time I'm
going to skip this figure and just go
going to uh explain about this last
figure so in this last figure now this
is actually summarization of all the
experiment here we are looking at three
different uh
viscosity and the vertical axis is the
relative error horizontal axis is the
super resolution ratio and and uh
different color means the
different uh uh noise noise level so
that uh going from top to bottom we have
we have noise from CH noise level
changing from 1.6 to zero so that the
the the line on the bottom is actually
Noise free uh super resolution case so
what the first thing we notice is that
if you look at if you see the figures
the the line here is C to the
minus5 so we actually see that when we
increase the compression ratio the error
is decre error error decreases but the
the but the ratio that error decreases
is actually much slower than the
theoretical predictions in theoretical
predictions we predicted C to Theus one
but in numerical experiment we have C
minus5
but one uh reason that we have uh slower
convergence is because of the you
because we are using a low low order of
cfd solver for The Observers the ground
truth was generated by Spectral method
while the low uh Observer was solved by
second or the final element method the
reason we use a low order obser low
order CF solver for the Observer is that
uh we want to mimic the real life
scenario where we don't really have that
kind of high resolution in for we don't
really have that kind of High Fidelity
models to reconstruct the velocity field
so if you use the if you use uh like
highly accurate pseudo spectral method
then this uh eror this noise free
reconstruction should going further down
here so that uh it it actually should
converge to the ground truth with the
motion accuracy but instead of instead
since we are using low low water sorber
we have the finite error and this final
error May contribute to this slow decay
of the uh of the
error uh we observe in numerical
experiment and another observation is
that uh as we increase the compression
ratio and as we reduce the viscosity
then now the relative error for
decreases but it's now starting to
increase as we uh as we increase the
super resolution ratio C so it's because
as we in in smaller viscosity we have
more strict uh regularity conditions and
then uh if we use higher compression
ratio and eventually we are going to we
are we are violating the necessary
conditions for the
convergence now uh we finally get to the
uh conclusions so in conclusions uh what
we have have done is more like a
theoretical analysis of super
resolutions we try to provide some
guidelines where theoretical
understanding why the super resolution
works or if super resolution of this
complex system actually uh works so that
and what you found is the
counterintuitively uh this the analyses
indicate a this decrease of estimation
eror that was very interesting but uh
one of the so in in this summary what
the most interesting part is the last
item that uh there is a limitations of
the current study because the theoretic
analysis is mostly limited to isotropic
flows and the estimate we are getting is
very conservative meaning that the arrow
bound we provide as a zone of
convergence actually should be much
larger than what it should be so we are
it it's actually for the followup study
that we are looking at then how can you
expand the current analyses to more
complex flows such as some in
homogeneous turent flows and how can you
get a more sharper Arrow bound than what
we currently have so far so thank you
for your attention
and this is talk thank you thank you so
much for the wonderful talk very
fascinating um awesome uh let's have a
Q&A sessions okay so there are some
questions in the chat room
by Sean um I think he already left but
he said thank you for the nice talk
perhaps a uh Missing reference from Tama
he was sharing so there's a link for the
paper okay and he wanted to share with
you okay uh the next question is by
Kevin he is asking what's an intuitive
explanation for the increasing accuracy
with Corsa mesh while measurement noise
is smoothed out by Cora mesh high
frequency flow features can be preserved
by Observer flow
model yes that yeah that's actually a
very very good question so that one is
that we are smoothing
out by using this
filter naturally we are smoothing out
the uh noise then that that's good but
also we are smoing out the small scale
features together with the noise so that
the question is that there is a balance
that uh and so that even though we are
sming out the small high like high wave
number of features by using this
observer in nication uh we have some
kind there is energy Cascade is
happening that is the uh that is energy
is is cascading from small large scales
to small scales and when we have suff
when when this uh
have uh when when this energy Cascade
happens at a certain scale less than uh
less than certain scales then uh we can
actually recover all these high scale
phenomena that's actually that's
actually what founding that's actually
what what we found in this study that
even though we have we don't have
information at very very small scale say
that even though we we filter all the
information about 10 15 times Comm scale
we can actually recover all of these
missing information
uh we can exactly recover all of these
missing informations by by through the
energy Cascade so that now the the what
we try to looking at is actually balance
between these two the one is that we are
having filtering effect but if we filter
too much then we cannot recover the
ground shoes so that we are looking at
the we we try to get a get a get a
theory that uh what how can you have the
balance between these noid filtering
effect as as the as the Reconstruction
of the ground
shoes I think your Arab bounds analysis
is kind of showing that story as well
right yes exactly so that course mes
doesn't shouldn't exceed certain uh
upper bounds otherwise you cannot
recover the The High Frequency yeah so
that's why we have this uh yeah we have
no we have this necessary condition and
this new is essentially the right hand
side Define the dissipation rate so that
each related to the Chromo scale in
turbulance so that H should be H the
that's the super ratio is a function of
some
scale yeah probably but but we actually
looked at 2D so
we that's that's also one of the
limitations of the current study I see
okay already fascinating for the two 2D
um next question is by Dave thank you
for a very interesting talk your
examples were for 2D turbulence where
the energy naturally flows from small to
large scales iners Cascade how would
your approach work for 3D turbulence
when the energy flows from large to
small scale that's a that's a good
question uh that that's very good
question um we Frankly Speaking we again
that that's actually why why I have the
last item uh in the in the conclusions
that we we certainly uh admit that there
are limitations of the current story and
because of the mathematic lack of
mathematical tools we usually cannot
it's very hard to go to 3D uh to to the
actual proof of converence in 3D
tobulance but what we have seen is that
there is some physical uh Explorations
about what's happening in 3D flows so in
this study they actually uh show
they they have some theoretical
derivations of the uh say critical
length scale to recover uh the high
resolution information so we believe
that the similar Behavior can be
observed in 3D but the actual
mathematical proof of convergence is it
still long way to
go okay all right uh next question is by
Shima thank you so much for such a great
talk I really enjoyed it I'm uh also
curious about about 3D flow which is
more important
okay question okay we are working on it
but it's a it's a tricky takes time
everything takes time uh understand uh
that's awesome okay so I'm I guess I can
ask questions um related to the the
fates questions in the beginning um you
know observing the preserving the those
conservation of law or some physical
property uh that's still challenging yes
to accomplish right right okay so the
deying models um always the tricky part
is
that how can it make
aut you know incorporate hard constraint
is always tricky part so that we have
like a many feable solutions and we want
to reduce the space of solutions that is
actually not mathematically feasible the
physically feasible but but that process
is still open Cas I
believe yeah but still I mean the the
work you have presented today is is very
impressive um already thank you yeah
thank you so I keep up the good work I I
think it's uh we can wrap up the the
seminar today um let's thank our speaker
for the wonderful talk and um through
this opportunity and we can you know you
know establish some a collaboration
between Lawrence Lima and your group and
in the future we can do greater things
together um that's all for that thank
you so much for the wonderful talk thank
you yeah okay that concludes today's uh
the seminar